We're helping people who are struggling through
their dating experiences and rejoining me
is friend of the show and relationship expert,
Damona Hoffman.
Hi Damona.
(audience clapping)
Hey Drew.
Okay, now we just met Katie,
who is like, you know, no nonsense about the dates.
If she's not into it, Damona said do a screening,
and that way you don't even have to waste time
on the actual physical date.
Susan met a guy, actually online, in a virtual date
and he showed up naked.
But now we want to hear from a gentleman, okay?
Christian is here
and he's been having a hard time letting go.
Christian, what is going on in your dating life?
Talk to us.
Thanks for having me.
I went on a few dates with someone,
and then they said that they just weren't that into it.
What's your best advice on getting over someone
that you've only been on a few dates with?
Is it okay if I ask them to tell me
what went wrong between us?
Oh, Christian, Christian, you're a catch.
You don't need to chase that kind of closure, right?
Like sometimes something goes wrong
and we think, it must've been something that I did,
or there must be something that is causing this to happen.
But sometimes it's just not a match,
and trying to get that information,
you expend a lot of emotional energy, right?
So, I like to think that everyone comes into your life
for a reason,
but not everybody is there for a romantic connection.
And so I take that Marie Kondo philosophy
of thank and release,
if you've ever, like, cleaned out your closets with that.
It's the same thing.
Everyone comes in for a reason.
You thank them for the time that you spent together,
and then you release them back into the wild.
If you notice this as a pattern
and all of your relationships always end the same way,
at the same time,
then we can talk about what you might be doing
and how we might address your strategy.
But otherwise, I want you to just go forward confidently
and know that that person wasn't a fit,
but if you keep at it,
you will find somebody that is the right match for you.
Also, I have to say, anyone, Damona's right,
if it's a constant pattern,
then we've got to do some looking.
But thank people for not wasting your time.
Staying in longer is longer drag out,
waste of time in life, longer to get over,
they're time saving you time.
Susan, Damona's right.
Don't let one naked man ruin it for everyone
and associate dating apps, because they are, you know,
what's happening now, with that one experience,
'cause you are amazing
and deserve whatever it is you're looking for.
And Katie, I like your no-nonsense ways.
You're gonna save yourself some time,
and thanks to Damona, now you've found out a way to do that.
I want to thank everybody for being on the show.
I love love, relationships, dating, I love dissecting it.
It's so fun.
Thank you so much.
(upbeat music)